it is wonderful to be here in Helsinki
this evening at a pivotal moment in our
shared history it's pivotal
because as I also discussed uh with
colleagues with the Prime Minister
Anderson in Sweden the Russian invasion
of Ukraine has changed the equation of
European security and it has Rewritten
our reality and reshaped our future
we've seen the end of the post-cold war
period and the invasion of Ukraine sadly
has opened a new chapter
and that Invasion has already failed for
two reasons
firstly because of the unbreakable
Spirit of the Ukrainian people who have
fought back and rallied the world behind
them
and second because that Ukrainian
struggle for Freedom that heroic fight
has brought the world together in
condemnation of this assault on our
values and
it would be fair to say that it has also
brought Finland Finland and the UK even
closer together today
so the security declaration the solemn
declaration we've signed today ensures
that our two our two Nations can
intensify our partnership and take it to
unparalleled Heights both latitudinal
and metaphorical from The High North to
the baltics and beyond our Armed Forces
will train operate and exercise together
marrying our defense and security
capabilities and formalizing a pledge
that we will always come to one
another's Aid
because this is not a short-term stop
cap uh sadly this is not a short term
stop Gap as you consider NATO membership
but an enduring Assurance between two
Nations an assurance that brings us ever
closer as we Face the challenges of
today the threats of Tomorrow side by
side
thank you very much thank you